sorting through the wreckage after a
deadly tornado ripped through Lee County
in southeast Alabama alongside the
cleanup effort an urgent search for the
missing there are areas I understand
they still have not been able to get
into yet and search the rubble there are
adults as well as children involved how
many I cannot tell you at this time
authorities do know that more than 20
people were killed when the storm hit on
Sunday winds of around a hundred and 60
miles per hour flattening homes snapping
trees and powerlines the looming funnel
cloud clearly visible from the
neighboring state of Georgia words
cannot describe it
trailer homes turned upside down damaged
this is unbelievable
it just took pine trees and cut them in
half telephone poles cut them in half at
the school it took a 12-ton air
conditioner picking nothing through it
at 40 feet some like this woman are
lucky to have escaped at all but now she
and many others face a colossal
challenge the trail of destruction the
tornado left behind is at points half a
mile wide and there's little comfort to
be found here as residents try to come
to terms with what's happened
the basic cleaner has already begun but
it will be a long time before this small
community is back to normal
Hanna Thomas Peter Sky News in New York